bonjour à tous aujourd'hui une courte
vidéo pour vous parler du d'abeilles ou
d'abeille ou d'ici qu'est ce qu'on va
voir on a banni la bbc c'est la
conférence des développeurs d'apple qui
auront lieu très très très très très
prochainement à san jose aux états unis
alors la question est qu'est-ce qu'on a
retrouvé du point de vue logiciel du
point de vue matériel
on va regarder ça assez rapidement et
une offre très très très rapidement
parce que justement cette abominable
difficile arrive d'ici quelques jours on
y va maintenant
le daba guides aveugles ici c'est la
worldwide developers conference d'apple
qui allie tous les ans au mois de juin
cette année c'est du 4 au je vous dise
pas de bêtises au 8 juin l'acquis note
aura lieu le 4 juin 19h heure française
a lieu à san jose aux états unis et
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait retrouver c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que on sait
qu'apple donne un petit peu le coup de
la tête
effectivement ou du point de vue des
smartphones des ordinateurs des ong pas
mal de choses apple n'est pas présent
partout mais dans les domaines sur
lesquels ils sont en règle générale ils
ont plutôt tendance à vendre bonne
réussite
le tabloïd avait lui dit si c'est
vraiment l'événement qui est plutôt
tournés du côté des développeurs mais le
monde entier de latex le regarde parce
que tout simplement elle sentit le
logiciel du point de vue d'apple sont
vraiment très forte et continue inspirer
énormément de développeurs énormément de
grandes entreprises du pôle du matériel
c'est exactement la même chose alors
qu'est ce qu'on va avoir cette année du
point de vue logiciel et du poids du
matériel
on va tout de suite alors justement on
va commencer par le point de vue
logiciel déjà du point de vue logiciel
osera voir eyeos 12 la nouvelle version
l'année dernière à ios 11 ans lui a
reproché pas mal de choses notamment des
petits couacs des petits problèmes à ios
12 viendrait corriger ces problèmes
n'ont pas révolutionné loes mais
vraiment apporté de la stabilité et de
la sécurité
ça sera vraiment l'essence comptera dans
cette ago s12 pas d'accueil revue et
visitée pas d'innovations majeures en
terme de navigation
l'ol devrait pas changer de tête il
faudra effectivement quelques nouveautés
il va toujours y avoir quelques
innovations bien évidemment met l'accent
sur ios 12 sera vraiment mis sur la
sécurité et sur la stabilité
mac os devrait y avoir une version accès
sécurité il ya une faille de sécurité
qui est ami effectivement en avance sur
le mac os actuel
la nouvelle version de mac os devrait
venir le corriger apporter vraiment
encore plus de sécurité et une fois de
plus on va pas avoir d'innovation énorme
d'inondations majeures mais vraiment
plus de sécurité plus de stabilité du
côté de gucci os pour votre apple watch
qui est ici on doit toujours plus dans
le sens de la santé connectés et du
fitness des innovations bien évidemment
qu'on va imaginer pour aller faire du
sport pour avoir de la santé prédictive
savoir comment vous allez est ce que
votre corps est bien est ce que vous
avez pas bon des défaillances est
toujours mieux informés et toujours
optimiser son exercice physique
vous allez voir si mise à jour de tv ou
est ce pour encore plus compatible avec
l'application au d'apple une mise à jour
également deux audio s pour le hall
potes qui permettrait d'aller encore
plus loin en termes de multi en 5 en
termes de stéréo
du côté logiciel on attend également le
projet marcipont gens n'y parlait déjà
il ya quelques temps du projet nancy
plan consisterait à unifier
l'environnement mac os et ios pour que
les développeurs puissent codé d'une
seule et même façon et ensuite ça puisse
se dispatcher a priori ce projet mardi
plan n'aurait pas lieu cette année
aura-t-il lieu un jour bon pour
l'instant en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'ils n'arriveraient pas
probablement pas avant 2019
du côté matériel net on attend des
grandes nouveautés à commencer par
l'ipad pro et quelques mois peu la
sortie son ipad 9,7 pouces 2 db 18
compatible avec le stylet d'apple où
l'attendait pas de preuve qui vient
confirmer le côté très haut de gamme du
produit qui va vraiment se différencier
de l'ipad 9,7 pouces peut être un
nouveau style est toujours plus de
précisions quelque chose d'encore plus
puissant qui permettra effectivement
d'aller plus loin à usage professionnel
on peut imaginer faith heidi même si
effectivement ça peut paraître compliqué
de se dire où est ce qu'on va loger une
petite encoche cependant plus que l'on
peut utiliser dans tous les sens est-ce
qui va y avoir une encoche est
d'ailleurs passé il dit bon pourquoi pas
maintenant ça aurait quand même un vrai
sens on attend le lancement officiel de
air power et repower c'est la base de
rechargement pour ipad et pour iphone
sans fil l'année dernière il a été
présenté on l'attend est toujours
annoncée sur le site d'apple comme étant
nouveautés de mes 18 pour l'instant que
toujours pas là on espère qu'elle avait
d'abord dit si tim cook nous confirmera
la sortie et qui puisse arriver très
rapidement que ceux qui souhaitent
profiter de la recharge sans fil avec
cette grande borne de recharge signé
apple
on attend également de nouveaux macbook
il faut être équipé de la huitième
génération du processeur intel un
nouveau macbook pro un nouveau macbook
air aussi qui pourrait enfin arrivé pour
le macbook pro en attend un correctif du
clavier à mécanisme papillon qui avait
tendance à africains des petites
cochonneries et qui pourrait poser des
problèmes sur certaines touches
apple pourrait corriger ce problème et
proposer un clavier revu et corrigé
justement et on attend également de
nouvelles fonctionnalités au niveau de
la touch bart ordinateurs toujours plus
puissants et toujours très haut de gamme
le mac pro sortira pas cette année il
est effectivement confirmée par apple
qu'il devrait sortir en 2010 neuf donc
pour tous les professionnels qui veulent
un mac pro alors encore s'armer de
patience et notre grand produit qu'on
attend c'est l'iphone s2 est ce que cet
iphone s 2
evra lahoud abominable dc est ce qu'il
arrivera plus tôt en septembre
est ce qu'il arrivera est ce qu'il
arrivera pas c'est un peu l'inconnue du
moment néanmoins on s'attend vraiment
c'était puisse être annoncée aux
d'abeilles ou d'abeille ou 10
l'iphone est ce dieu va être une version
revue et corrigée de l'iphone et seul
iphone et ceux qui encore beaucoup de
succès ceux qui veulent des iphone avec
des écrans compacte du cas de pouce du
petit volume qui tient dans la poche qui
sera forcément d'être de ces grands
écrans pourraient être vraiment
satisfait cet iphone s 2 il pourrait
être néanmoins revu et corrigé avec une
petite encoche sur le haut qui dit
encoches dit fayçal dit ça c'est aussi
un peu l'interrogation parce que
j'imagine que faith heidi coûte cher et
l'équipe est sur un produit milieu de
gamme de chez apple
ça pourrait être aussi un peu compliqué
mais on la retrouve des fuites notamment
publié sur le site ce match 6 qui montre
un écran avec une encoche est cet iphone
s2 aura bien cette encoches oui ou non
c'est un vrai point d'interrogation
toujours est il que cet iphone s2
resterez compact aurait un dos en verre
qu'on permettre la recharge à induction
un châssis en aluminium
il pourrait profiter de la puce à 11
bionique pour avoir toujours plus de
puissance et être le produit le plus
compact avec la meilleure puissance
qu'on puisse en trouver sur le marché
mais néanmoins elle garderait un écran
lcd tout simplement pour une question de
coût il pour harmoniser les gammes
j'imagine très très très très
difficilement qu'il peut émettre de
l'écran oled partout et ça permettrait
aux clients comprendre quel est le
produit haut de gamme le produit milieu
de gamme très clairement sur ce produit
il est sûr et certain qu'on gardera un
écran lcd et côté tarif il traite
proposant un tarif aux alentours des 500
euros voilà pour les grandes lignes de
ce que ça te retrouver au d'abeilles ou
d'abeille ou dc cette année alors soyez
connecté rester connecté parce que le 4
juin à 19 heures je l'aide derrière mon
écran je vous ferais bien évidemment
plusieurs vidéos pour reprendre les
annonces phares les produits phares voir
un peu les nouveautés voir si c'est
intéressant de les acheter oui ou non
s'il faut attendre voir s'il faut se
positionner en décident d'un petit peut
analyser tout ça une fois que les
annonce aurait été faite par tim cook
en attendant vous invite à vous abonner
a blessé deux jolies pouces a marqué
toutes vos questions suggestions
directement aux commentaires en dessous
restez connectés parce que vous allez
voir il ya plein de nouveautés plein de
choses plainte est plein de produits
punk n o qui arrive donc on reste
ensemble d'ici là soyez ça je vous
embrasse et à très bientôt
ciao